a million questions i want to ask but uh
rereading uh some of the some of the um
uh
fire and ice uh books i was thinking
about reek
um could you talk a little bit about
that character because honestly
tyrion is a lot of fun to read and
anticipate
but reek absolutely just tortures me to
read
those chapters it just really kind of
just gets to me
can you talk about what there are three
wreaths
you know there's the original reek who
is dead
and then there was the fake greek who
was actually
ramsey bolton who pretended to be greek
because uh
you know he didn't want to be executed
the final request and then the final
who is uh of course theon greyjoy who is
being made into
reek his personality destroyed by uh
by torture uh by ramsay
you know i wanted to show the
disintegration of personality and the
things that can happen you know
under uh sufficient amount of torture
and
you know breaking someone's breaking
someone's mind and will
um hard stuff to write
although to be fair to myself i i didn't
actually write most of it i presented
most of it in flashback
you know as opposed to the tv show which
actually showed a lot more of it but
in the books i skipped over most of that
i let you think that theon is dead for a
while and then reap comes back and
hopefully it
takes you a while to realize who it
actually is
thank you sure hello my name is swanna
and
i want to say thank you first for
writing the books because they were my
escape from
a not so pretty neighborhood in brooklyn
that i grew up in
oh okay well thank you and it's kind of
a two-part question
you said that every character has a
portion of you what part does the
character
brand have of you and why do you find it
so hard to
write bran bran is the youngest of all
the viewpoint characters that's why
he's the hardest to write and he's also
the one most involved with magic and
these
are both challenges when you're writing
from the viewpoint of a
of a young child you can't just write
what's happening you have to write
what's happening you have to make it
clear to the reader
what's actually happening and
but you have to phrase it from a child's
eyes what does
the child think is happening you know
for example in the in the very first
brand chapter where he
he was the second brand chapter where he
catches jamie and cersei
having sex he he's he doesn't know about
sex he's
like seven years old and he just sees
naked people wrestling or something like
that
he's not quite comprehending but you
have to do that kind of thing in life
you can't just
write what's happening you have to look
at every sentence and say okay
this is what's happening i gotta make it
clear so the reader understands but
i gotta put it through you know through
the years
the eyes of the of an eight-year-old or
seven-year-old so that's part of your
challenge
and the other part of it is magic
a fantasy novel requires magic
but it has to be handled very carefully
i think
obviously you can see in
ice and fire a basically
low magic approach to fantasy many
fantasies are very high magic almost
all of them are more more high magic
than what i do
and to my mind that's the problem with a
lot of them because magic
you know you can put too much magic in
and and it
it it can potentially destroy a thing
it's it's like a little salt and a stew
a little
makes the soup taste better too much
salt and you ruin the stew
thank you thank you
hey hi my name is marissa thank you
again for coming to roanoke
um i'm really interested in how many
point of view characters you have in the
song of ice and color
[Applause]
some of them never meant to be point of
view characters they just push their way
in
annoying
i have three in my book and i originally
had four and just had to get rid of one
so it was too much so how do you balance
having so many point of view characters
do you ever go like oh crap i have two
aria sections two clips together and
have to shuffle things over yeah i do
that constantly you'd be amazed how much
time i spend
reshuffling the order of the chapters
you know
um you know it was it
hopefully got a laugh here too many but
in some ways it is true
um certain events i wanted to portray
i i could never quite find the right
point of view character to
to capture the scene so i wound up using
multiple point of view characters
you know that in the last book i talked
a great deal on my blog about the
marines not
you know i kept rewriting those chapters
in marine because i i had like three or
four
point of view characters coming together
and and you know who
people who were traveling to murray
danny was already in marine and
other people were traveling to marine
and they were arriving and what order
should they arrive in and
i would write the chapter and then i
would rewrite the check now this one
should write first and i'll rewrite the
chapter and
because that would change everything and
but some of the people would arrive they
didn't speak the language they didn't
really know what was going on i'm
presenting
a i'm trying to present some fairly
complicated political maneuverings and
plots
from the viewpoint of someone who
doesn't speak of language or know
anybody
uh that was difficult and i finally
i finally solved the marinades and i
finally cut through it after
several different approaches by
introducing stan as a dewpoint character
and that was the solution but it also
gave me another point of view character
that i didn't originally intend to be
appointed character
um so you know sometimes that's the way
it happens
okay thank you hi i'm justin i also want
to thank you for coming out to see us
my pleasure i know we've seen a lot of
what happens to
various star children over the course of
the books but one of them seems to have
really fallen off the map
what's going on with rickon
keep reading i definitely plan on
[Music]